قصف وقصف مضاد وصل صداه فورا الى واشنطن
وكثير من الوفود التي توقيع اتفاقين
للسلام بين تل ابيب وكل من ابو ظبي
والمنامه ما تزال في باحات البيت الابيض
لعلها صوره مصغره لما قد يمكن لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط ان تعيشه جراء ذلك التطبيع
الفلسطينييون وشعوب المنطقه يقولون بوضوح
انه مرفوض مرفوض ورئيس الحكومه الفلسطينيه
يؤكد ان صمود شعبه وثباته على ارضه سيفجان
كل المؤامرات التي تحاك ضد قضيته في ايران
مثلا قال الرئيس روحاني ان على الدول
العربيه التي تطبع مع اسرائيل تحمل تبعات
قرارها الذي من شانه زعزعه الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه فهل يقود التطبيع
الى السلام والوئام ام ينسف اسس الامن
والاستقرار
غزن زيارات اللبيب ارجوك يا النشم
اللبيب ونهج رهيب عاشت امارات السلام ذاك
ربما ما تحلم به تلبيب اي الهج باسمها في
الاغاني وان يتمنى عرب زيارتها ويناشد
نشمي لبيبا ليعبد لهم الطريق اليها
الاغنيه اماراتيه وهنا على رمال الصحراء
في تلك البلاد وجدت عارضات اسرائيليات
ضالته لعرض بثياب النوم الصوره تبدو خادعه
وان كانت حقيقيه فخلف ح قائق اخرى اكثر
واقعيه
وقسوه صاحب القضيه نفسه يرى ان لا سلام
عادلا يخفس من فوق حقوقه لا يرفع اللافتات
فحسب بل يتحين الفرص وبينما كان نتنياهو
يلقي كلمته في الاحتفال الباذخ في البيت
الابيض كان هناك من يقصف بصواريخ اسدود
المدينه التي لها ميناء شهير نحن هنا يقول
لنتنياهو ومن اجتمعوا حوله لم تكن صواريخ
المقاومه في حاله سدود ردا على عدوان مادي
بادرت اليه اسرائيل بل رساله مثقله
بالدلالات بعثها الفلسطينيون لمن يعنيهم
الامر بان لا امن لاحد ما دامت حقوقهم
مهدوره في البيت الابيض بدات الصوره
سينمائيه بامتياز رئيس في نهايه ولايته
يقود اثنتين من الدول العربيه الثريه الى
توقيع معاهدات سلام مع اسرائيل القى ترامب
وكذلك ضيوفه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ووزير خارج الامار والبحرين كلمات تتحدث
عن حقبه جديده في الشرق الاوسط وعن امل
جديد بالسلام في المنطقه لكن اي منهم لم
يتطرق الى وضع الفلسطينيين او الى سبيل
تفكيك اسباب الصراع في المنطقه امر يقول
كثيرون انه يقصر مفهوم السلام على جانب
دلالي واحد ويعزله عن مفهومي الامن
والاستقرار الذين بدونهما لا يتحقق السلام
وحسب هؤلاء فان اقامه ابو ظبي والمنا
علاقات مع تل ابيب لا تبدو قفزه في الفراغ
فحسب بل من شانها الاضرار بدول عديده في
المنطقه وسكب مزيد من الزيت على النار
فيها فاسرائيل تصر على ان ضم نحو ثلث
الضفه الغربيه علق ولم يلغى وهي وواشنطن
تريان ان من اهداف توقيع الاتفاقات التصد
لايران في المنطقه وهو ما فهم منه بعض
تحويل ابو ظبي والمنامه الى قاعدتين
متقدمين لاسرائيل في مواجهه طهران وذاك ما
تحدثت عنه ايران وحذرت من تبعاته حيث يرى
حسن روحاني ان على من يطبع ان يتحمل
تداعيات قراره الذي يزعزع الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه برمتها على حد
تعبير الرئيس الايراني ولم يجد روحاني
حرجا في تذكير بعض حكام المنطقه بعروبته
قائلا اين عروبتكم يا من لا تدركون معنى
الدين والواجب ازاء الشعب الفلسطيني قال
ذلك ايضا وبلغه اكثر حده سياسيون وجنرال
ايرانيون محذرين من تاثيرات وجود اسرائيل
بالقرب من بلادهم جراء اتفاقات السلام
وتوعدوا بان لا تمر مساله كهذه ويحدث كل
ذلك بينما بدات خطط ما يسميه بعض التحالف
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي تظهر علنا في اجزاء
من المنطقه ففي جزيره سقطره اليمنيه تعتزم
تل ابيب وابو ظبي اقامه قواعد تجسس هناك
لمراقبه حركه الملاحه في البحر الاحمر
وباب المندب وصول الى منطقه القرن
الافريقي وهو ما يعني لمراقبين نفوذا
يتزايد لاسرائيل ما كانت لتحلم به لولا ان
ثمه حصان طرواده عربيا يسهل لها مهمتها بل
يتقدمها لانفاذ خططها في التوسع
والسيطره لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من القدس عميحاي شتاين المحلل في الشؤون
الدبلوماسيه في قناه كان العبريه معنا
ايضا من عمان عبر الانترنت اللواء طيار
مامون ابو نوار الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بكم ابدا معك سيد
عميحاي شتاين ونبدا اسرائيليا وعلى ضوء ما
حدث بالامس من اشتباكات بالتزامن مع توقيع
اتفاقي تطبيع في البيت الابيض في العاصمه
الامريكيه يعني ما هي جدوى اتفاقات
التطبيع هذه لاسرائيل
في وقت لا تجب لها اولا الامن اسرائيل على
ارضها اذا هذه نقطه مثيره للاهتمام لان
التوقيع مع البحرين والامارات العربيه
المتحده هي في حقيقه الامر اسرائيل ليست
في صراع مباشر معها
والصواريخ التي اطلقتها المنظمات المنظمه
الارهابيه من
غزه اوصلتنا الى موقف تذكر ان هنالك مشكله
داخليه امنيه في
اسرائيل كما تعرفون هنا كان لدينا توقيع
لاتفاقيه سلام مع بلدين لذلك هنالك فرق
كبير الشعور الان
كان احتفاليا بشكل كبير لكن الصواريخ
ذكرتنا ان اسرائيل تعاني من مشاكل
الداخليه وان هذه الاتفاقات لن تحلها
واعتقدوا ان الرد كان اكثر قوه من اعتاد
ربما لاظهار ولاظهار للناس انه
هنالك ما يزال قتال وما تزال هنالك صواريخ
تسقط على اسرائيل نعم هنالك اتفاق سلام
هناك لكن الواقع مختلف ذلك الموقف صعب جدا
وعلي ان اقول ان ما سمعناه من المواطنين
في جنوب اسرائيل كانوا يشعرون بخيبه الامل
لعدم تحرك الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضد غزه
لذلك ربما نوعا ما
جعلت هذا الاحتفال في واشنطن اقل ابتهاجا
مما كان يج اذا يعني كل ما ذكرت الى اي
مدى يمكن ان يفند او يفند و وليس يمكن
يفند كل ما يسوق له رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بان هذه الاتفاقات هي ستدر او
تاتي بهذه المليارات اولا الزهار
الاقتصادي في ظل سلام تنعم به اسرائيل
وتفتح الباب امام فجر سلام وكل هذا
التسويق الى اي مدى تكذب وتفند كل ما يقال
على لسان
نتنياهو لا اعتقدوا ان هذا سيكون كان ضظ
لكنه ربما تذكير للاسرائيليين انه لدينا
مشاكل داخليه الس هنا الرد هناك من اليمين
واليسار كلا كلاهما كان يحتفلون بالاتفاق
اتفاق السلام مع الامارات والبحرين لكن
بالنسبه لنتنياهو علي ان اقول انه عندما
سمع بمساله الهجوم الصاروخي من غزه بعد
انتهاء الاحتفال اعتقد ان الامر كان مخيبا
للامال بالنسبه له عندما يكون هنالك وسائل
الاعلام الاساسيه ووسائل الاخبار الاساس
هنالك احتفال في واشنطن ومن جهه اخرى
هنالك هجوم صاروخي تم اعتراضه هنا اعتقد
ان هذا الامر لا يلغي الاحتفال لكنه كما
قلت تذكير للاسرائيليين انه وكما قلت هو
رساله من غزه من تلك المنظمه الارهابيه
الى رئيس الوزراء متنيا اننا ما نزال هنا
وليس اي هنالك اتفاق سلام مع اي دوله
عربيه ستحل الوضع اللواء مامون يعني في ظل
هذه الرساله التي اصبحت واضحه الان لرئيس
الوزراء يعني برايك الى اي من يمكن الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تمضي او هذه المواجهه ما
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه من جهه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه من جهه اخرى
في ظل هذه
الاتفاقات يعني اسرائيل هي ما تفعله يتسق
تماما ومنسجم تماما مع الانظمه
الاستعماريه عنصريه ضيفك منت الابي ما
بعرف منين بتكلم لكن قال الارهابيين من
غزه يعني هل الحق تقرير المصير الشعوب
اصبح ارهابي من هو الارهابي اسرائيل اطلقت
حكم مؤبد على غزه بالحصار جو بحر يعني هذا
خطر على الانسانيه تجويع الناس بهذا الشكل
ايضا بالضفه الغربيه تحاصرهم وتتحكم بكل
شيء التطبيع الذي حصل
اعتقد لن يكون ورقه
مساومه لحل الدولتين حل الدولتين يجب ان
يسبق مثل هذا التطبيع ما فعلوه الاخوه
الامارات
والبحرينيين يعني اعلنوا استقلالهم عن
العالم العربي الغوا المبادره العربيه
وزي ما جاء بتقرير سيدتي انهم علقوا الضم
والامارات بتقول لا اوقفنا الضم ب ما
معناه فيعني عباره عن فيلم هلود ما ما
رايناه بالنسبه للمقاومه يعني اي غزه
وداخل الضفه يعني يعرفوا اسرائيل تماما هم
اكثر الشعوب الذين يعرفوا اسرائيل غاياته
اهدافه نياته
اي الى ذلك من الامور الان الوضع خطير جدا
واعتقد يجب ان اي جماعه الاخوه في الداخل
الاراضي المحتله
يجب ان يفعلوا شيئا ما كفاح شعبي ومذل
خطير الى اي يعني تقول بان الوضع خطير جدا
المقاومه فصال المقاومه الغرفه المشتركه
بالاحرى ل فصال المقاومه الفلسطينيه تقول
اليوم بانها ستواجه القصف بالقصف وانها
لديها القدره بان توقف كما تقول او تمنع
اسرائيل من تغيير قواعد الاشتباك الى اي
مدى لديها القوه والقدره النوعيه لان تردع
اسرائيل
بالفعل هي ردعت اسرائيل واسرائيل دائما
يعني لا يوجد لها مخرج من غزه حتى لو فكرت
ان تحتل غزه تقسمها الى قسمين وتدخل فيها
هذه سوف تكون حرب دمويه طبعا الموازين
القوه لصالح اسرائيل ان لاقول لكن
المقاومه في غزه تستطيع يعني ان تؤثر على
الداخل
و تجعل السكان الاسرائيليين داخل الملاجئ
هي اوق عملت حذر جوي كامل فوق اسرائيل
سيكلفها هذا اقتصاديا
سياسيا يعني لديهم القدره لوصول لاي هدف
في اسرائيل الان وضربه
اي عندهم القوه الكامله بهذا
لكن هل هذا ممكن ان يحصل لكن ما تعودنا
عليه كل ثلاث اربع سنوات تقوم اسرائيل
بحرب على غزه ثالث حروب
و يعني كل اللي بتقوم فيه بالقصف الجوي
هذه جرائم حرب تحاسب عليها نعم مع ذلك في
مقاومه لكن ما يحزن في الامر ان ال دوله
مثل مصر تحاصر ايضا دوله شقيقه وتعمل
الاسوار الاسمنتيه داخل الارض وخارجها
والصور الالكتروني وغرقت الانفاق بالمياه
هذا محزن جدا ل يعني طيب اود ل ماذا يحصل
بالتعامل مع هذه الدول يعني يعني اعود لك
سيده شتاين يعني وعلى ذكر مصر اسرائيل
التي ابرمت اتفاقات مع الاردن
ومع مصر في 79 في عام 94 هل برايكم يعني
وجهه نظر اسرائيليه بانها اصبحت دوله اكثر
قبولا في
المنطقه نعم نعم هذا ليس سؤال بدون اي شك
لدينا بلدان وقعا اتفاقيه مع اسرايل في
اقل من شهر ولدينا دول مثل السودان وعمان
ممثلين ايضا قد قد اتوا والتي اسرائيل ليس
لديها علاقات دبلوماسيه كانوا حاضرين هناك
لذلك هذا تشعر اسرائيل انها اكثر مقب هنا
عن علاقات اسرائيل مع الجهه الرسميه لكن
شعبيا مازالت اسرائيل مرفوضه لدى هذه
الدولتين
هذا هو الفرق حقيقه في هذه النقطه عندما
راينا الشركات من الامارات العربيه
المتحده والبحرين مثلا شركات تتحدث عن
التبادل
الثقافي الروابط الاقتصاديه والتعاون
العلمي عندما ننظر الى هذه هذا المجال وما
يجري مع مصر
والاردن لدينا تعاون
رسمي امني لكن لا نرى في حقيقه الامر
تعاونا مع الشعوب او مع الشركات في تلك
الدول ربما العمليه ستبدا مع الدول
الخليجيه مع الامارات والبحرين ربما ستسبب
وستشجع شركات من الاردن ومن مصر ان تاتي
الى اسرائيل بالنسبه لمصر والاردن لا رنا
هنالك تمثيلا ش لهذه الشركات ان تاتي الى
مها اسرائ ليس محق اسرائيل حتى لهذه
الشركات فيما يتعلق عندما اوضح
هل تتحدثين عن الوضع الامني او عن وضع
الكوفيد 19
مثلا لا طبعا اتحدث عن الوضع الامني الان
في في اسرائيل في ظل هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
التهديدات من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه وفي ظل عدم اعطاء مثل هذه
الاتفاقات اي حقوق للفلسطينيين اي سلام
يتحدث عنه نتنياهو اذا داخل
حدوده مره اخرى تلك الشركات ستقول اذا ما
نظرنا الى الاتفاق مع الامارات والبحرين
تلك الشركات
تمح تحدثت عن القضيه الفلسطينيه بشكل غير
واضح لذلك حتى تلك
الدول عندما
كان كان هنالك حديث عن القضيه الفلسطينيه
وتلك الدول تقول اننا وضعنا هذه القضيه
جانبا لكن اعتقد ان الاختبار الحقيقي
للعلاقات مع الامارات ومع البحرين قد ياتي
ربما اذا ما
اسرائيل قامت باخذ خطوه في الضفه الغربيه
ربما توسيع للمستوطنات او ربما عمليه في
غزه ربما هذا سيكون الاختبار الحقيقي
للعلاقات مع تلك الدولتين كيف سيكون رد
فعلهما اذا ما قامت اسرائيل باتخاذ مثل
هذه الخطوه لانه من وجهه النظر العربيه
هذا الامر
ضد ما يجب ان يكون لذلك اعتقد ان هذا هو
الاختبار
الحقيقي لهذه لقوه ومتانه هذه العلاقات
اذا اشكرك من القدس عمي حاي شتاين المحلل
في الشؤون الدبلوماسيه في قناه ك كان
العبريه وينضم الينا الان من غزه صالح
النعامي المحلل السياسي والباحث المتخصص
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك سيد صالح
نعامي يعني تحدث محمد شيه اليوم عن الرؤيه
الفلسطينيه ل ل عمليه السلام الامريكيه
قال بانها تتكون من ثلاثه نقاط اولا هي
الاجراءات العقابيه ووقف التمويل ثانيا
تطبيع مع العرب وثالثا تنفيذ خطه الضم
يعني في ضوء هذه الرؤيه الفلسطينيه
الواضحه التي باتت واضحه الان لكم كيف
ستواجهون هذا
الامر انا في تقديري التحدي الاول امام
الفلسطينيون امام الفلسطينيين هو استعاده
الوحده الوطنيه والشروع فورا بتطبيق ما تم
الاتفاق عليه
مؤخرا ما بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه وتحديدا
تفعيل المقاومه
الشعبيه يجب ان يكون هناك الامر
واضح هذا الاحتلال يجب ان يجبى منه ثمنا
مقابل جرائمه المتواصله ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني ما كان على مدى السنوات الاخيره
من انقسام وهذا الانقسام الذي سمح للكيان
الصهيوني بهامش مناوره كبير
سواء في العمل ضد قطاع غزه المقاومه في
القطاع وضد السلطه الفلسطينيه وضد الضفه
الغربيه عبر السباحه الارض الفلسطينيه
التهويد والاستيطان هذا يجب ان يتوقف الان
التحدي هو ان تتحول ان يتحول ما يقول
الدكتور شتيه وما اعلنه قبل فتره اللواء
جبير جوب ان يتحول هذا الى برنامج عملي
واضح و وانا هنا اتحدث عن لا اتحدث عن
موضوع العوده يعني او التوافق على الكفاح
المسلح يعني حتى لا تتحمل السلطه حتى لا
تتحمل السلطه وزر وزر وتبعات البرنامج
برنامج حركه حماس او برنامج الجهاد يجب ان
يتم التوافق على مساله المقاومه الشعبيه
المقاومه الشعبيه ذات الاسنان المقاومه
الشعبيه التي تكون تؤذي الاحتلال بمعنى
انه اذا قام الاحتلال مثلا يعني بتدشين
طريق التفافي على ارض الارض فلسطينيه اذا
تم مصده ارض فلسطينيه عندما تقوم منظمه
شاره ثمن الارهابيه اليهوديه باقتحام
القرى في الضفه الغربيه والبلدات واحراق
المساجد والبيوت كما يحدث كل يوم يجب ان
يكون هناك فعل شعبي فلسطيني مؤثر انا في
تقديري هذا ليس فقط سيضمن بعوده القضيه
الفلسطينيه الى مكانتها وصدته بل انه
سيمثل اوضح واقوى رد على اولئك الذين كل
ما يعنيهم هو ان ان يراكم
شرعيه خارجيه لد لد الايكان تقول بان هذه
التطورات الجديده وهذه اتفاقيات التطبيع
سوف تؤثر على الاولويات الفلسطينيه وتعيد
ترتيبها من
جديد هذا طبعا طبعا بكل تاكيد لانه علينا
ان نتذكر استاذه ايمان ما ما بين الفتره
94 والعام 2000 كما تذكرين كانت طبعا كان
كانت هناك موجه تطبيق انا في تقديري اعتى
من هذه الموجه كثير من الدول العربيه
اقامت ممثليات لها في في العديد من الدول
العربيه
واصبح رؤساء الوزراء والوزراء
الاسرائيليين يجولون في في طول العالم
العربي و وعرضه ولكن عندما اندلعت ثوره
انتفاضه الاقصى كما تذكرين كل هذا الامر
تبخر واجبر الفلسطينيون العالم العربي
والانظمه العربيه سواء بارادتها وبدون
ارادتها الى وقف هذا هذه الموجه وبالتالي
انا في تقدير هذا ما سيحدث الان الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يمكن ان يسلم بان يبقى هذا
الحل يعني خطوره الامر بالنسسبه لل
بالنسبه لاتفاق التطبيع يعني الفلسطيني
ليس امام طرف خيارات كما كما وضع كما كان
واضحا في الاتفاق احد البنود يتحدث عن
تعاون ما بين الامارات والبحرين من جهه
واسرائيل في مواجهه ما يسمى الارهاب يعني
بمعنى اسرائيل ترى في المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ارهابا وبالتالي هذا تشريع ل التعاون ما
بين هذه الدول واسرائيل في مواجهه
المقاومه ومواجهه الشعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي يجب ان يضح ان يوضح الشعب
الفلسطيني عبر يعني فعل مقاوم كبير واصيل
بانه انه انه مصمم على احباط هذا التوجه
وانا في تقديري كما نجح الفلسطينيون في
عام 2000 سينجح سينجحون هذه المره وبشكل
يق كل التوقعات لك سيد اللواء مامون يعني
في المقابل هناك من
تصريحات الايرانيه ما يهدد اسرائيل وهي قد
اصبحت على مرمى حجر يعني من ايران وخصوصا
ان يعني ما لبثت هذه اتفاقيات التطبيع ان
تنتهي في واشنطن ويعلن اليوم
عن ربما تعاون اماراتي اسرائيلي او ما
سماه البعض تحالفا اسرائيليا
اماراتيا توجد فيه او تبعث فيه بعض القوات
الى سقطره وهناك ايضا موطئ قدم لها في
البحر الاحمر برايك ما ما يعني ما رايك في
لهجه التهديد الايرانيه هذه الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تاخذها اسرائيل على محمل
الجد يجب ان تاخذها على محمل الجهد وان لا
تتجاهل هذا لكن عر ثواني يعني الوضع في
الضفه لابد من كفاح شعبي انا اعيد واكرر
لانه قبل الانتخابات هذا مهم جدا الوحده
الوطنيه مهمه جدا الانتخابات ايضا مهمه
جدا كشريه وكمه ايضا و ويقول العالم يعني
نحن نقاوم ونفا وض وهو هذا الشيء الطبيعي
لانهاء اي نزاع لن يحدث اي سلام الا من
خلال الفلسطينيين بالنسبه لايران اعتقد ال
ايران لا تهتم كثيرا بما يحدث لان اي
لديها القوه والنفوذ لتهدد هؤلاء يعني
الامارات لا تحمل مع الاسف يعني اقول هذا
اربع خمس صواريخ بالستي مع شويه كروس توقف
البلاد كل كليا القواعد شراء الاف 35 هي
اللي بيحكوا عنها ايضا يعني لن تغير قواعد
اللعبه انا فني واعرف ما اقول ممكن يعني
اذا بدهم يضربوا المفاعل حتى لو بده
يضربوا المفاعل لن ينفع ذلك ايران لديها
القدره في صدهم كلهم بوسط الصواريخ
والنفوذ
ووكلائها في المنطقه من الصعب جدا
واسرائيل لن تجر يعني ان تناوش ايران او
تتحرش بها باي منطقه اما ممكن ان يكون
هنالك
استخبارات عاليه مع الاقمار الصناعيه مع
الى ذلك وشفنا يعني بال بالاحتفال كيف
انهم طلعوا للمريخ ونزلوا والى اخره من
الامور
يران دوله قويه مسيطره على النفوذ الباب
المندب من خلال الحوثي اللي بتحرش في
السفن الامريكيه ووقفت السعوديه ايضا
ال البحر العرب ايضا يعني ايران لديها
النفوذ لتتعامل مع اي حالات طارئه والردع
لكن هذا سوف يحرق المنطقه وهم يعوا ذلك
تماما واعتقد يعني ال الخليج مقسم يعني ال
حتى لو النيتو العربي اللي بيحكوا فيه
كثير هذا حتى مصر انسحبت منه يعني لم تؤمن
فيه فلا اعتقد يعني لا قطر لا الكويت لا
عمان سوف تسمح يعني ب في عمليه القتال هي
حتى التركيه ال باكستان يعني لن تعطي
الامريكان قواعد والى اخره فاذا كانوا
بتوقع انه اسرائيل سوف تحميهم فهم مخطئون
بذلك كليا من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه انا
اقول اي وايران موجوده والحوار العقلاني
الاستراتيجي الحديث معها هو الشيء الصحيح
يعني بالنسبه لداير في المنطقه ا اتحول
اليك سيد نعامي ونعود الى الوضع الفلسطيني
الذي قال
فيه الفلسطينيون اليوم بان اتفاقات
التطبيع سوف هي ضربه هي ضرب للاجماع
العربي كما يقولون
ولكنها لن تغير شيئا في الواقع كيف ذلك ما
وجهه هذا الحديث يعني بان هذه الاتفاقيات
كما استمعنا لن تغير شيئا في واقع
الفلسطينيين انا في تقديري التصعيد بالامس
اطلاق الصواريخ على العمق الصهيوني هذا
كرس هذه الرساله بشكل واضح وهو بالمناسبه
انطوى على ثلاثه رسائل اساسيه الرساله
الاولى بانه بانه لا استقرار ولا سلام في
المنطقه بدون استعاده الحقوق الوطنيه
للشعب الفلسطيني الرساله الثانيه بانه ليس
من حق طبعا بالمناسبه هم يتحدثون عن سلام
مع انه هذه الدول لا البحرين ولا الامارات
لم تخذ حربا مع مع الكيان الصيني بالعكس
كانت على مدى العقود الثلاثه الاخيره في
تحالف سري مع مع هذا الكيان الرساله
الثانيه انه ليس ب يعني من حق احد من ليس
من حق نظام عربي من اجل مراكبه شرعيه لدى
الامريكان ان ان يتحدث باسم الفلسطينيين
وان يوافق كما فو في الاتفاق على موضوع
الضم وعلى موضوع ان حتى غياب الحديث عن حل
الدولتين وان يتم تحويل القدس لكنهم
يطبعون ويسم ويسمونها يعني اتفاقيات سلام
بدل اتفاقيات تطبيع وم تحدثون عن ازدهار
في الاقتصاد
و والكثير من مما سمعته في الايام الماضيه
ويؤكد نتنياهو بان خطه الضم معلقه يعني
ليست ليست ملغيه ما زالت قائمه لكن نتحدث
عمليا الان ماذا على ماذا
تعول انا كما قلت يا استاذه ايمان التعويل
الاساسي للشعب الفلسطيني الان على على نعم
نعم على على على خيار الشعب الفلسطيني
الوحيد الان وهو المقاومه و وطبعا كما تم
التوافق مؤخرا على مساله المقاومه الشعبيه
حتى تكون مظله بامكان جميع الفصائل ان ان
ان يستظل بها لا اقول والله انه مساله
الكفاح المسلح التي قد تحرج البعض
المقاومه الشعبيه التي تشكل تحديا للكيان
الصهيوني هذا الكيان طالما يعني ما لم
يشعر بانه هناك ثمه ثم الثمن يجبى منه
بالمناسبه اسرائيل لم تفكر في مساله مساله
الانسحاب من الاراضي الفلسطينيه ولم تخرج
المنظمات اليساريه في اسرائيل المطالبه
بالانسحاب من الضفه الغربيه الا بعد الا
في ظل الانتفاضه الاولى ولم تخرج المنظمات
الشعبيه الاسرائيلي مطالبه بالخروج من
جنوب لبنان الا بعد اندلاع المقاومه
اللبنانيه وبالتالي هذا هذا هو تحدي هو
يعني تفعيل المقاومه ال
الشعبيه وفي مرحله لاحقه حتى المقاومه بكل
اشكالها نعم نعم لا شك انها تحديات كبيره
تواجه الفلسطينيه في المرحله المقبله شكرا
لك من غزه صالح النعامي المحلل السياسي
والباحث المتخصص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
كذلك اشكرك لواء طيار مامون ابو نوار
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
عمان